- ברוכים הבאים חזרה להבנת
מידע קוונטי וחישוב.
שמי John Watrous, ואני
המנהל הטכני של IBM Quantum Education.
זה השיעור הרביעי בסדרה וזה השיעור
האחרון ביחידה הראשונה של הסדרה על היסודות
של מידע קוונטי.
עד כה, דיברנו על
איך מידע קוונטי עובד גם למערכות בודדות וגם למרובות, הסתכלנו על
מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי,
וראינו כמה
מגבלות בסיסיות על מידע קוונטי.
לאורך הדרך,
נתקלנו בכמה מושגים מתמטיים חשובים
כולל מכפלות טנזוריות ומכפלות פנימיות, ונמשיך
להשתמש במושגים האלה ונציג כמה חדשים
גם כן לפי הצורך.
בשיעור הזה, נתמקד
בשלוש דוגמאות בסיסיות וחשובות, טלפורטציה קוונטית, קידוד סופר-צפוף ומשחק CHSH,
שנקרא גם אי-השוויון של CHSH ולא תמיד מתואר כמשחק.
אלה לא סתם דוגמאות
אקראיות שנועדו להמחיש איך מידע קוונטי עובד, הן באמת חלקים מרכזיים
של היסוד
של מידע קוונטי והן
עולות בהקשרים שונים ולפעמים בלתי צפויים בתוך מידע קוונטי
וחישוב.
שזירה ממלאת תפקיד מרכזי בכל שלוש
הדוגמאות האלה, ולמעשה, שזירה היא מה שגורם להן לעבוד
ומה שהופך אותן למעניינות. אז, השיעור הזה יהיה, במובן מסוים, ההזדמנות הראשונה שלנו
לראות שזירה בפעולה
ולהתחיל לחקור מה זה שהופך שזירה לכל כך מעניינת.
הסקירה של
השיעור פשוטה מאוד, נעבור אחת אחת
דרך שלוש הדוגמאות שהזכרתי עכשיו,
טלפורטציה קוונטית,
קידוד סופר-צפוף, ומשחק CHSH.
נדון מה הדברים האלה ומה הופך אותם למעניינים ונעבור דרך ניתוחים שמסבירים בדיוק איך הם עובדים
ברמה מתמטית.
לפני שנגיע לדוגמה הראשונה
מבין השלוש, שהיא טלפורטציה קוונטית, מתאים קודם
להציג את הדמויות,
Alice ו-Bob, למקרה שאתם
לא מכירים אותם.
Alice ו-Bob, הם שמות
שניתנים לישויות או סוכנים היפותטיים במערכות, פרוטוקולים, משחקים,
ובאמת בכל סוג אחר של אינטראקציה שתרצו לשקול שכוללת חילופי מידע.
הם הופיעו לראשונה
בהקשר של קריפטוגרפיה בשנות ה-70, אבל
המוסכמה להשתמש בשמות האלה בצורה הזו הפכה לנפוצה מאוד
בהקשר הרבה יותר רחב מאז. הרעיון הוא שאלה
שמות מאוד נפוצים, לפחות בחלקים מסוימים של העולם, והם מתחילים באותיות A ו-B,
וזה גם נוח
להתייחס ל-Alice ול-Bob באמצעות כינויי הגוף שלה ושלו רק לשם קיצור.
בדרך כלל אנחנו מדמיינים ש-Alice ו-Bob נמצאים במיקומים שונים ושיש להם מטרות
שונות והתנהגויות שונות
בהתאם למה שאנחנו מדברים עליו.
למשל, אם אנחנו
מדברים על תקשורת, כלומר, העברת מידע, אז אנחנו יכולים להחליט
ש-Alice היא השולחת
ו-Bob הוא המקבל
של כל מידע שמועבר.
לפעמים Alice ו-Bob
משתפים פעולה, זה מאוד טיפוסי, אבל לפעמים הם
מתחרים או שיש להם מטרות שונות שיכולות
להיות או לא להיות עקביות
אחת עם השנייה, אבל זה
הכל צריך להיות ברור במצב הנתון.
כמובן, הם מייצגים הפשטות ולא בהכרח בני אדם ממשיים.
אנחנו יכולים גם להציג
דמויות נוספות כמו Charlie ו-
Diane או שמות שונים שמייצגים פרסונות שונות
כמו Eve
עבור מצותתת או Mallory עבור מישהו שמתנהג בזדון
בהתאם להקשר.
בכל מקרה, נראה את Alice ו-Bob בכל שלוש
הדוגמאות שנדון בהן בשיעור הזה ומדי פעם
לאורך שאר הסדרה. אני גם אעשה כמה
הערות על שזירה לפני שנעבור לשלוש הדוגמאות.
בשיעור שני, נתקלנו בדוגמה הזו של מצב שזור של שני qubit-ים.
זה אחד מארבעת מצבי Bell, ואפשר לומר
שהמצב הספציפי הזה מייצג את הדוגמה הארכיטיפית
של מצב קוונטי שזור.
נתקלנו גם בדוגמה הזו
של מצב הסתברותי של שני ביטים.
זה אנלוגי למצב
השזור במובן מסוים, אבל זה לא שזור,
שזירה היא תופעה
קוונטית ייחודית,
בעצם מעצם ההגדרה.
יש הגדרה מתמטית מדויקת של מה זה שזירה ובעצם מה שההגדרה
אומרת היא ששזירה
היא קורלציה קוונטית לא-קלאסית.
אבל זה לא כל כך
מועיל ברמה האינטואיטיבית, זו הגדרה של שזירה במונחים של מה שזירה אינה,
וכנראה שבגלל זה
שבפועל זה די קשה להסביר מה זו שזירה ומה הופך אותה למיוחדת
במונחים אינטואיטיביים.
כשאנשים כן מנסים
להסביר מה זו שזירה במונחים אינטואיטיביים, אתם
לעיתים קרובות שומעים הסברים שבאמת לא
מבדילים בין שני המצבים האלה
בצורה משמעותית. אתם עשויים לשמוע את הרעיון
שאם מודדים אחד משני ה-qubit-ים השזורים,
אז המצב של השני
מושפע איכשהו באופן מיידי או שלא ניתן לתאר את המצב של שני ה-qubit-ים בנפרד
או ששני ה-qubit-ים
איכשהו שומרים זיכרון אחד של השני או אפילו
שהם קשורים רגשית בצורה כלשהי.
אבל למה התכונות האלה
לא נכונות למצב הזה?
שני הביטים האלה קשורים באופן הדוק, לכל אחד יש זיכרון
מושלם של השני במובן מילולי, אבל
זה לא מצב שזור.
ובכן, דרך אחת להסביר מה
הופך שזירה למיוחדת ומה הופך את המצב הזה
לשונה מאוד מהמצב הזה היא להסביר מה אנחנו
יכולים לעשות עם שזירה
או מה אנחנו יכולים לראות קורה
בגלל שזירה שחורג מההחלטות שאנחנו מקבלים לגבי איך אנחנו מייצגים את
הידע שלנו באמצעות וקטורים.
כל שלוש הדוגמאות
שנדון בהן בשיעור הזה הן מהאופי הזה בכך שהן ממחישות
דברים שאנחנו יכולים לעשות עם שזירה שאנחנו
לא יכולים לעשות עם המצב הזה
או עם כל מצב מתואם קלאסית.
אכן, זה מאוד טיפוסי בחקר מידע קוונטי וחישוב שאנחנו רואים שזירה כמשאב
שדרכו אפשר להשיג
משימות שונות.
וכשאנחנו עושים את זה, אנחנו רואים את המצב הזה כמייצג
יחידה אחת של שזירה.
אנחנו מתייחסים ליחידה הזו של
שזירה כ-e-bit, ה-e מייצג
שזור או שזירה.
זה נכון שזה שני qubit-ים, אבל ככמות של
שזירה, זה e-bit אחד.
אפשר גם לראות זוג
של ביטים קלאסיים רגילים במצב ההסתברותי
המתואם מקודם כמשאב שהוא
ביט אחד של אקראיות משותפת.
זה יכול להיות מאוד שימושי
בקריפטוגרפיה לחלוק ביט אקראי עם מישהו בהנחה
שאף אחד אחר לא יודע מה הביט הזה כדי שאפשר
יהיה להשתמש בו כמפתח פרטי
או כחלק ממפתח פרטי, למשל, לצורך הצפנה.
אבל בשיעור הזה, המיקוד שלנו יהיה על המצב השזור הזה ו
דברים שאנחנו יכולים לעשות איתו.
ורק כדי להבהיר את המינוח, כשאנחנו אומרים ש-Alice
ו-Bob חולקים e-bit, הכוונה היא ש-
Alice מחזיקה qubit בשם A,
ל-Bob יש qubit בשם B, ויחד הזוג A, B
נמצא במצב Phi plus.
לא חשוב אילו שמות
נבחר לשני ה-qubit-ים, כמובן, אפשר
לבחור שמות שונים, אבל לאורך השיעור הזה,
ניצמד לשמות האלה
לצורך בהירות. הדוגמה הראשונה של השיעור
היא טלפורטציה קוונטית,
שמכאן ואילך פשוט
נקרא לה טלפורטציה לשם קיצור.
מה שטלפורטציה היא זה פרוטוקול שמאפשר לשולח
להעביר מידע קוונטי למקבל באמצעות רק שזירה
ותקשורת קלאסית כדי
לבצע את ההעברה הזו.
אין לזה שום קשר לפרשנות הטיפוסית
של המילה טלפורטציה במדע בדיוני, שהיא
שחומר נעלם
במיקום אחד ומופיע באחר.
טלפורטציה קוונטית היא רק שם שנועד לעורר את זה כדימוי או כמטאפורה כביכול.
מה שמטולפרט הוא
מידע קוונטי ולא חומר, וזה קורה
דרך העברה של מידע קלאסי
יחד עם שזירה.
כדי להבין בדיוק
איך טלפורטציה עובדת, מועיל להתחיל
בהצבת הבמה, כביכול.
מה שנעשה זה לדמיין תרחיש שמערב את Alice ו-Bob ו
התרחיש הזה הוא כדלקמן,
ל-Alice יש qubit בשם Q שהיא
רוצה להעביר ל-Bob, כלומר שהיא
רוצה שBob יחזיק בידיים שלו
qubit שנמצא בדיוק
באותו מצב שQ נמצא בו כשהם מתחילים את הפרוטוקול.
במילים אחרות, אנחנו מדברים על הבעיה הבסיסית של
העברת מידע או תקשורת.
יש לנו שולחת בשם Alice
ומקבל בשם Bob ו-Alice רוצה לשלוח
מידע קוונטי בצורת qubit ל-Bob.
יש אילוץ, עם זאת, שהוא ש-Alice לא
מסוגלת לשלוח פיזית את Q ל-Bob, כל מה שהיא יכולה לעשות זה לשלוח מידע קלאסי ל-Bob.
ל-Alice ול-Bob יש גם
משאב נוסף, שהוא שהם חולקים e-bit.
אז זה התרחיש, קל
לדמיין מצבים שבהם האילוץ ש-
Alice לא יכולה לשלוח פיזית את Q
ל-Bob הוא הפשטה סבירה.
אם Alice ו-Bob היו על
יבשות שונות למשל, או אם Alice לא ידעה
את המיקום המדויק של Bob, אז שליחה פיזית של qubit
כנראה הייתה די מאתגרת.
אבל תקשורת קלאסית
כמובן לא רק אפשרית אלא די זולה
בנסיבות האלה.
עכשיו, אפשר לשאול האם אפשר ל-Alice ול-Bob להשיג את המשימה הזו בלי אפילו להזדקק ל-e-bit המשותף.
במילים אחרות, האם יש
דרך כלשהי להעביר qubit באמצעות תקשורת
קלאסית בלבד?
התשובה היא לא, לא ניתן להעביר מידע קוונטי באמצעות תקשורת קלאסית בלבד, וזה לא כל כך קשה להוכיח
באמצעות קצת תורת מידע
קוונטי בסיסית, שנראה ביחידה
השלישית של הסדרה.
לעת עתה, דרך אינטואיטיבית
לחשוב על זה היא לחשוב על משפט אי-השכפול.
תדמיינו שהייתה דרך
לשלוח מידע קוונטי באמצעות תקשורת קלאסית בלבד,
אבל תקשורת קלאסית
אפשר בקלות להעתיק ולשדר, אז זה אומר
שהתקשורת הקלאסית
יכלה להישלח לשני
מקבלים, Bob ו-Charlie, נגיד.
אם שניהם קיבלו את
אותו מידע קלאסי מ-Alice, אז האם
שניהם היו מסיימים עם Q?
זה היה מרמז שהעתקנו את Q, אבל אנחנו יודעים שזה בלתי אפשרי.
רק כהערת אגב, בואו
נשים לב שבהחלט אפשר לתאר
וקטורי מצב קוונטיים באמצעות מידע קלאסי.
כל וקטור מצב קוונטי
שתראו בסדרה מתואר לכם
באמצעות מידע קלאסי שהועבר לכל
מכשיר שאתם צופים בו.
באופן כללי, אנחנו יכולים לדמיין
תיאור של המצב שQ נמצא בו באמצעות ביטים קלאסיים
אולי עד רמת דיוק מסוימת,
אבל זו לא תקשורת קוונטית, זה רק לתאר
מצבים קוונטיים כוקטורים, ונחזור להבחנה
ביניהם
עוד רגע קט.
אבל בחזרה לתרחיש, ותחת
ההנחה ש-Alice ו-Bob כן חולקים e-bit, נראה
ש-Alice ו-Bob
יש להם את כל מה שהם צריכים
כדי להשיג את המשימה, וזה מה שפרוטוקול
הטלפורטציה הקוונטית עושה, ספציפית באמצעות שני ביטים
של תקשורת קלאסית.
לפני שנכנסים
לפרטים האלה, עם זאת, תנו לי להעיר כמה הערות
מהירות רק כדי לוודא שההנחות ברורות.
ראשית, אנחנו מניחים
כאן שהמצב של Q לא ידוע ל-Alice ו-
Bob, אז בפרט,
Alice לא יכולה לשלוח ל-Bob
תיאור של המצב Q כי היא לא יודעת אותו באופן כללי.
אנחנו גם צריכים לשקול את האפשרות ש-Q מתואם עם מערכות אחרות, כולל האפשרות
שהוא שזור
עם מערכות אחרות וה
העברה של ה-qubit הזה ל-Bob חייבת לשמר את הקורלציות האלה.
לבסוף, הזכרתי
את משפט אי-השכפול כשדיברתי על
ניסיון לתקשר qubit-ים באופן קלאסי, אבל
יש כאן קשר נוסף
עם משפט אי-השכפול, שהוא שאם Bob
מקבל את ההעברה של ה-qubit Q הזה מ-Alice,
אז היא כבר לא יכולה להחזיק בו
כי Q לא ניתן לשכפול, וזה פשוט משהו שכדאי לזכור
כשאנחנו שוקלים את פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה.
פרוטוקול
הטלפורטציה אפשר לתאר בצורה די פשוטה וישירה עם דיאגרמת circuit קוונטי כפי שאתם יכולים לראות ממש כאן.
זה קצת מסוגנן בכך
שזה מתאר את ההפרדה בין החלק של Alice לחלק של Bob, אבל מלבד זאת, זו סתם
דיאגרמת circuit קוונטי,
כל מה שמעל הקו המקווקו
מייצג את הפעולות של Alice וכל מה שמתחת
מייצג את הפעולות של Bob.
הזמן הולך משמאל לימין כתמיד, ואנחנו רואים שאנחנו מתחילים
עם שני ה-qubit-ים האלה כאן שנמצאים במצב Phi plus,
אז זה ה-e-bit
ש-Alice ו-Bob מתחילים איתו.
אנחנו יכולים לשים תוויות על ה-qubit-ים כדי להבהיר מי זה
מי, אז זה ה-qubit A, וזה ה-qubit
B שמרכיבים את ה-e-bit,
וזה ה-qubit Q ש-
Alice רוצה להעביר ל-Bob.
כאן אנחנו מניחים שהמצב
של ה-qubit Q הזה הוא Psi, אבל קצת יותר מאוחר נשקול את האפשרות
ש-Q שזור
עם מערכת אחרת כלשהי. ומה שהדיאגרמה טוענת כי כתבנו psi כאן למטה,
היא שה-circuit הזה
למעשה מעביר את כל מצב psi שהיה
לנו כאן למעלה בצד של Alice לכאן למטה בצד של Bob,
התקשורת היחידה
שעוברת את הקו
בין Alice ל-Bob היא שני הביטים הקלאסיים
שמיוצגים על ידי הקווים הכפולים האלה ממש כאן.
בואו נכווץ את
הדיאגרמה הזו קצת כדי שיהיה לנו קצת יותר מקום ובואו נבחן את
ה-circuit מקרוב.
כבר תיארתי
את התנאים ההתחלתיים, אבל רק לסכם, Alice מחזיקה qubit A
ו-Bob מחזיק qubit B,
כאשר A ו-B ביחד
נמצאים במצב Phi plus, אז זה מה שזה אומר לחלוק e-bit.
ל-Alice יש גם את ה-qubit Q הזה שהיא רוצה להעביר ל-Bob, ואנחנו שוקלים את המקרה ש-Q נמצא במצב קוונטי שרירותי כלשהו Psi.
עכשיו, אנחנו לא יודעים שום דבר
על איך Alice ו-Bob הגיעו להחזיק ב-e-bit הזה.
יכול להיות שהם
החזיקו בו הרבה זמן, אולי הם יצרו אותו מזמן כשהיו באותו מיקום
והם שמרו
אותו להזדמנות הזו, אבל הפרטים האלה לא רלוונטיים כאן.
הצעדים שקורים הלאה, שמייצגים את
פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה עצמו הם כדלקמן, ורק כדי להבהיר,
אלה הצעדים שה
דיאגרמה מתארת ואנחנו פשוט נכתוב
אותם במילים כדי שיהיה ברור מה
הדיאגרמה מבטאת.
Alice קודם מבצעת פעולת
controlled-NOT כאשר ה-qubit Q שהיא
רוצה לשלוח ל-Bob הוא הבקרה וה-
qubit A הוא המטרה.
הצעד הבא הוא שהיא
מבצעת פעולת Hadamard על Q, ואז היא מודדת
את שני ה-qubit-ים שהיא מחזיקה,
A ו-Q ביחס
למדידות בסיס סטנדרטי ונסמן ב-a קטנה את התוצאה של המדידה של ה-qubit A,
ונסמן ב-b קטנה את התוצאה של המדידה של ה-qubit Q.
Alice אז שולחת את שני
הביטים הקלאסיים האלה ל-Bob וזו התקשורת היחידה שמעורבת בפרוטוקול הזה וזה מצוין בדיאגרמה
על ידי העובדה ששני
הביטים האלה חוצים את הקו המקווקו בין Alice ל-Bob,
שאפשר לחשוב עליו כמייצג את כל
המרחק שמפריד ביניהם.
אחרי ש-Bob מקבל את הביטים
a ו-b, הוא עושה שני דברים.
ראשית, אם a שווה לאחד, אז הוא מבצע פעולת X
או במילים אחרות, gate NOT על ה-qubit B שלו,
ואחרת אם a שווה לאפס, אז הוא לא עושה את זה.
ובאותו אופן,
אם b שווה לאחד, אז Bob מבצע פעולת Z
או Z-gate או היפוך פאזה
גם על ה-qubit b וכמו
קודם, אם b שווה לאפס, אז הוא לא עושה את זה.
כל זה מצוין באיור שבו יש לנו gate-ים
controlled-X ו-controlled-Z כאשר הבקרות הן
שני הביטים הקלאסיים.
אתם לא חייבים לחשוב על ה-gate-ים האלה בתור control gate-ים
אם אתם לא רוצים, זו רק דרך נוחה
לבטא את מה שאנחנו רוצים
בצורת דיאגרמת circuit. הנקודה היא ש-Bob מפעיל
X-gate על ה-qubit b אם a שווה לאחד ו
אז הוא מפעיל Z-gate
על ה-qubit b אם B שווה לאחד.
ולשם נוחות מאוחר יותר אנחנו יכולים לכתוב במפורש
את הפעולה המשולבת ש-Bob מבצע על ה-qubit b שלו,
בהתאם לביטים הקלאסיים
ש-Alice שולחת.
אז זה פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה, זה די פשוט באמת, ה
עובדה שזה באמת עובד זה עניין אחר
ולמרות שהניתוח
לא כל כך מסובך,
אתם לא צריכים להרגיש שמשהו חסר לכם אם אתם לא מיד רואים למה זה עובד.
בגלל זה אנחנו צריכים
לעבור דרך ניתוח וזה מה שנעשה עכשיו.
כדי לנתח את פרוטוקול הטלפורטציה, נעבור דרכו צעד אחר צעד כדי לראות מה המצבים
של שלושת ה-qubit-ים בנקודות שונות בזמן.
קודם נשקול
את המקרה שה-qubit העליון נמצא במצב אלפא אפס ועוד בטא אחד, כאשר אלפא ובטא
הם מספרים מרוכבים כלשהם
שגורמים לוקטור הזה
להיות וקטור יחידה.
זה ה-qubit Q ש-
Alice מנסה להעביר, אבל לא באמת אכפת לנו איך
קוראים לו ברגע הזה.
קצת יותר מאוחר,
נסתכל על המצב שבו ה-qubit הזה
שזור עם מערכת אחרת, אבל זו נקודת התחלה טובה
רק כדי לשמור על פשטות
ולראות איך הניתוח
עובד קצת יותר בבירור.
אם נשקול את המצב של
שלושת ה-qubit-ים ביחד כאן בהתחלה, נראה
שהמצב הזה בצורה שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
שני ה-qubit-ים הראשונים
נמצאים במצב Phi plus, ה-qubit השלישי הוא העליון
לפי המוסכמה
לסידור qubit-ים שתיארתי
בשיעור הקודם, ואז אנחנו לוקחים את המכפלה הטנזורית כדי לקבל את המצב של
שלושת ה-qubit-ים ביחד.
אנחנו יכולים לפרוש את הביטוי הזה
על ידי הצבת ההגדרה של מצב Phi plus קודם ואז חישוב המכפלה הטנזורית
ואנחנו מקבלים את המצב
שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
זו לא תמיד האסטרטגיה
הטובה ביותר אגב, לפרוש לגמרי
וקטור כזה, בדרך כלל רעיון טוב לחכות עד ש
יש לכם סיבה טובה לעשות את זה.
אבל כאן יש לנו סיבה, שהיא שנרצה
לחשב את הפעולה של ה-controlled NOT gate הזה ועל ידי כתיבת המצב בצורה הזו,
אנחנו יכולים לעשות את זה בקלות רבה.
ובפרט, זה
המצב של שלושת ה-qubit-ים אחרי שה-controlled NOT gate מופעל.
ה-qubit השלישי הוא qubit הבקרה כי הוא זה שנמצא
למעלה לפי המוסכמה שלנו, וה-qubit השני,
שהוא האמצעי,
הוא המטרה, אז אנחנו פשוט
פועלים על הקטים בהתאם, אם הביט השלישי הוא
אפס, שום דבר לא קורה,
ואם הביט השלישי הוא אחד,
אז אנחנו הופכים את הביט השני.
אז אנחנו מבצעים את
ה-Hadamard gate על ה-qubit השלישי, אנחנו יכולים לכתוב את הוקטור
שמתקבל כפי שאתם יכולים לראות
ממש כאן על ידי הצבת
מצב הפלוס ומצב המינוס במקום מצב האפס ומצב האחד.
ואם אנחנו רוצים מספיק
מקום לפרוש את זה, נצטרך לכווץ
את זה קצת ועכשיו, על ידי הצבת
מצבי הפלוס והמינוס
עם ההגדרות שלהם,
הכנסת השורש הריבועי של שתיים למכנה, אנחנו מקבלים את המצב שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
ועל ידי פריסת זה, אנחנו מקבלים את המצב שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
אז, זה המצב של שלושת ה-qubit-ים אחרי ש-Alice מבצעת את שתי הפעולות שלה.
Alice אז מודדת
ואם אנחנו רוצים לנתח את המדידות, מה שאנחנו עושים זה לבודד את וקטורי הבסיס הסטנדרטי
עבור המערכות שנמדדות
בדיוק כפי שדיברנו עליו בשיעור שני, ואם נעשה את זה במקרה הספציפי הזה, זה מה שנקבל.
ואם תסתכלו על הביטוי
הזה לרגע, זה עשוי להיראות קצת מוזר כי עכשיו נראה שה-qubit הראשון,
שהוא ה-qubit התחתון
איכשהו תלוי באלפא ובטא, למרות שב
נקודה הזו לא הייתה תקשורת מעבר לקו המקווקו,
אבל זו רק אשליה. זכרו שסקלרים צפים
חופשי דרך מכפלות טנזוריות, אז באמת אין שום מובן
שבו אלפא ובטא
משויכים ל-qubit הראשון.
כל מה שבאמת עשינו
כאן זה להשתמש בסוגריים בהתאם
למולטי-ליניאריות של מכפלות טנזוריות.
בכל מקרה, זו הצורה שאנחנו צריכים כדי לראות מה המדידה עושה, ואנחנו יכולים לראות דבר אחד
מעניין מיד
וזה שההסתברויות של ארבע תוצאות המדידה האפשריות תמיד אחידות.
ההסתברות למדוד כל
זוג של תוצאות מדידה היא רבע, אז, בפרט,
אין שום תלות
כלל באלפא ובטא.
אנחנו יכולים לראות את זה בכל מקרה על ידי חישוב הנורמה האוקלידית בריבוע של
כל וקטור שממוכפל טנזורית עם וקטור הבסיס הסטנדרטי
שבודדנו,
ובכל מקרה יש לנו רבע שמתקבל מריבוע של חצי כפול הערך המוחלט בריבוע של אלפא
ועוד הערך המוחלט
בריבוע של בטא, שזה אחד, ואז נקבל רבע בכל מקרה.
זה די חשוב
למעשה שההסתברויות של התוצאות השונות האלה לא תלויות בשום צורה ב-qubit ש-
Alice רוצה להעביר.
לא ייתכן שמצב שרירותי נכנס כאן למעלה ויוצא כאן למטה וגם מדידה חשפה
מידע על המצב הזה.
אם אתם רוצים להשיג מידע על מצב קוונטי שרירותי, אתם תצטרכו להפריע
למצב הזה באופן כללי.
הנה טבלה שמתארת לא רק את ההסתברויות
של התוצאות השונות, אלא גם את המצב של
שלושת ה-qubit-ים ביחד
בהתנייה על כל תוצאת מדידה
אפשרית.
אנחנו מקבלים את זה על ידי נרמול הוקטורים שממוכפלים טנזורית עם
מצבי הבסיס הסטנדרטי השונים, אבל זה קל במקרה הזה,
אנחנו פשוט מסירים את הגורם של חצי כדי לקבל וקטור יחידה.
אז, מה שיש לנו מיד
אחרי ש-Alice מודדת זה ש-Alice מחזיקה שני ביטים
אקראיים אחידים וזהו.
בפרט, כבר אין לה
את המצב המקורי ואין לה שום
מידע עליו, יש לה רק ביטים אקראיים.
המצב של Bob עכשיו כן
תלוי באלפא ובטא וגם בתוצאות המדידה.
אם נדמיין לרגע
ש-Alice עדיין לא שלחה את תוצאות המדידה
כך ש-Bob לא יודע מה תוצאות המדידה,
אז הוא לא היה יכול
להשיג שום מידע על אלפא ובטא
ממדידת ה-qubit שלו.
ארבע האפשרויות
שיש לנו ממש כאן מספיק מעורבבות כדי להבטיח ששום מידע
על אלפא ובטא
לא ניתן אי פעם להשיג
דרך מדידה. זה חייב להיות נכון ברמה אינטואיטיבית כי אחרת הייתה לנו
תקשורת מהירה מאור.
Alice בהחלט לא יכולה
להעביר מידע ל-Bob בלי לשלוח שום דבר כלל, אבל כמובן Alice כן
שולחת את תוצאות המדידה
ל-Bob, אז בואו נרחיב את הטבלה כדי לראות מה קורה כאשר
Bob מבצע את הפעולות שלו.
בעמודה הזו ממש כאן, יש לנו את הפעולות השונות ש-Bob למעשה מבצע עבור כל אחת מתוצאות המדידה
האפשריות
כפי שראינו קודם,
ואם נעבור אחת אחת ונפעיל את
הפעולה הזו על ה-qubit של Bob, שהוא הראשון, B,
נראה שנקבל את אותה
תוצאה בכל ארבעת המקרים והתוצאה הזו היא המצב המקורי.
אז, המצב המקורי של ה-qubit Q הועבר בהצלחה בטלפורטציה ל-B.
אם Bob רוצה לשנות את השם של ה-qubit שלו ולקרוא לו Q בשלב הזה, הוא בהחלט מוזמן לעשות את זה, אבל הנקודה היא שעכשיו
הוא מחזיק את המצב המקורי
ש-Alice החזיקה וכמובן מתוך הכרח, ל-Alice כבר אין אותו.
שימו לב גם שה-e-bit
למעשה נשרף דרך התהליך הזה,
לטלפורטציה יש עלות
והעלות היא e-bit אחד ושני ביטים קלאסיים של תקשורת, וכשהפרוטוקול
נגמר, ה-e-bit נעלם.
עכשיו הוכחנו שפרוטוקול
הטלפורטציה עובד נכון תחת ההנחה שה-qubit העליון נמצא במצב קוונטי
מהצורה אלפא כפול קט
אפס ועוד בטא כפול קט אחד.
אבל מה קורה אם ה-
qubit העליון שזור עם מערכת אחרת כלשהי כמו
אחד מה-qubit-ים הנוספים שלנו
כפי שיש לנו כאן על המסך? אולי נרצה להשתמש בטלפורטציה
בנסיבות כאלה.
אולי Alice ו-Bob בעצם
מתכננים לבצע טלפורטציה 100 פעמים כדי ש-Alice תוכל להעביר
רגיסטר קוונטי של 100 qubit-ים
ל-Bob, qubit אחד בכל פעם.
או אולי ה-qubit-ים הנוספים
האלה בכלל לא נמצאים ברשות Alice
ומישהו אחר מחזיק אותם, אולי Alice אפילו
לא יודעת שהם קיימים.
השאלה היא, האם
טלפורטציה עדיין עובדת למרות שה-qubit שעובר טלפורטציה שזור עם מערכת אחרת?
כאן, המצב של ה-qubit Q יחד עם המערכת הנוספת
שאנחנו שוקלים מבוטא כפי שאתם יכולים לראות ממש כאן למעלה
כאשר גמא אפס ו
גמא אחד הם וקטורי יחידה שמייצגים מצבים קוונטיים
של המערכת הנוספת הזו.
תמיד אפשר לכתוב מצב שרירותי של המערכת המשולבת בצורה הזו.
אנחנו בעצם לא
צריכים את אלפא ובטא כאן, אבל אם נכלול אותם,
אז אפשר לקחת גמא אפס וגמא אחד להיות וקטורי יחידה
וזה יהפוך את
הקשר למקרה הפשוט יותר שכבר בחנו ליותר שקוף.
אנחנו יכולים לעבור דרך
ניתוח דומה לזה שכבר עברנו, אבל כאשר אנחנו גם עוקבים
אחרי המערכת הנוספת הזו.
זה קצת יותר מבולגן כי יש לנו את המערכת הנוספת, אבל
הרעיון בדיוק אותו דבר, הנה סיכום מאוד מהיר.
זה המצב ההתחלתי, הנה המצב אחרי
ה-controlled NOT gate,
והנה המצב אחרי
פעולת ה-Hadamard.
אם נפרוש את הדברים
האלה, אפשר לבטא את המצב הזה כפי שאתם רואים ממש כאן,
זה המצב מיד
לפני המדידות של Alice, ואם נעבור דרך
האפשרויות בדיוק כמו קודם
ונשקול מה
קורה כש-Bob מפעיל את הפעולה שהוא אמור להפעיל,
אז נגלה שאכן
המצב הנכון יוצא והפרוטוקול עובד כצפוי.
בטבלה הזו אגב, אנחנו משתמשים באות R כדי
להתייחס למערכת הנוספת הזו, ואתם יכולים לראות שאנחנו
משתמשים בטריק די פשוט,
שהוא להחליט שאנחנו מעדיפים, לפחות לרגע, לסדר
את המערכות כ-B, R, A, Q
כי זה יותר נוח לכתיבת המצבים ממש כאן.
לפי הדיאגרמה, המערכות צריכות להיות
מסודרות כ-B, A, Q, R,
אבל כל עוד אנחנו מבהירים את זה, אנחנו יכולים לבחור סדר
שונה שנוח יותר.
בקצרה, כל מה שקורה בניתוח הזה הוא
אותו דבר כמו מה שקרה בניתוח הפשוט יותר,
אבל במקרה יש לנו
את הוקטורים הנוספים האלה, גמא אפס וגמא אחד
שבעצם באים לנסיעה.
תמיד יש לנו גמא אפס
כשיש גורם של אלפא וגמא אחד כש
יש גורם של בטא ובסוף היום,
הכל מסתדר נכון.
זה בעצם בכלל לא מפתיע, יש לנו תהליך פיזי שמתנהג כפעולת הזהות
על qubit
במצב קוונטי שרירותי, ויש רק
דרך אחת שזה יכול לקרות והיא שהפעולה
היא פעולת הזהות.
זה קצת יותר קל להסביר באמצעות הניסוח הכללי
של מידע קוונטי, אבל הנקודה היא שמתוך ליניאריות,
באמת לא היינו צריכים לעבור דרך הניתוח הנוסף הזה.
ברגע שאנחנו יודעים ש
טלפורטציה עובדת נכון עבור qubit בודד בבידוד, אנחנו יכולים להסיק שיש
רק דבר אפשרי אחד
שיכול לתאר מה הפרוטוקול עושה, וזה שהוא מיישם
את פעולת הזהות כאשר qubit נכנס ממש כאן
ויוצא ממש כאן, ופועל למעשה כערוץ קוונטי
מושלם ונטול רעש.
רק כמה הערות מהירות
על טלפורטציה לפני שנעבור לדוגמה
השנייה של השיעור, שהיא קידוד סופר-צפוף.
ראשית, אני חושב שחשוב להבהיר שטלפורטציה היא לא יישום של מידע קוונטי, היא פרוטוקול
וספציפית היא
פרוטוקול לביצוע תקשורת קוונטית.
כדי שטלפורטציה
כפי שתיארתי אותה תהיה שימושית, חייבת להיות סיבה כלשהי לבצע תקשורת קוונטית.
שנית, סביר לשער שטלפורטציה יכולה, יום
אחד, להפוך לדרך סטנדרטית
לתקשר מידע קוונטי, וספציפית תהליך שנקרא זיקוק שזירה
עשוי לשמש
כדרך לתקשר qubit-ים באופן אמין. אם Alice ו-Bob יודעים שהם
הולכים לתקשר מידע קוונטי או שיש להם
צורך לתקשר
מידע קוונטי, אז תהליך זיקוק השזירה הזה
יכול לשמש להמרת מספר גדול יותר של e-bit-ים רועשים
למספר קטן יותר
של e-bit-ים באיכות גבוהה שאפשר להשתמש בהם לטלפורטציה נטולת רעש או כמעט נטולת רעש.
הרעיון הוא שתהליך
זיקוק השזירה לא כל כך עדין במובן מסוים, אנחנו יכולים לקבל הפסדים ו
אם זה לא מצליח,
אז אנחנו פשוט יכולים לנסות שוב, בעוד שה-qubit-ים בפועל ש
אנחנו רוצים לתקשר עשויים להיחשב הרבה יותר יקרי ערך.
כמובן, כל זה ספקולציה, אבל הנקודה היא שלא קשה לשער מצבים
שבהם טלפורטציה
יכולה להיות דרך מאוד מעשית
לתקשר qubit-ים.
והנקודה האחרונה
בנוגע לטלפורטציה היא שהרעיון מאחורי טלפורטציה והדרך שבה היא עובדת
הוא די בסיסי
במידע קוונטי וחישוב, טלפורטציה היא באמת אבן פינה של תורת המידע
הקוונטי ווריאציות
על הרעיון גם עולות לעיתים
קרובות, זו רק דוגמה אחת, יש הצעות ל
יישום gate-ים קוונטיים שונים
באמצעות טלפורטציה, אבל
כאשר מצבים התחלתיים שונים ומדידות שונות נבחרים
כך שהתוצאה
היא להפעיל פעולה נבחרת
במקום לתקשר.
הדוגמה הבאה היא קידוד סופר-צפוף.
כמו טלפורטציה קוונטית,
קידוד סופר-צפוף הוא פרוטוקול ומה שהוא משיג הוא משלים לטלפורטציה.
בעוד שטלפורטציה מאפשרת
העברה של qubit אחד באמצעות e-bit ושני
ביטים קלאסיים של תקשורת,
קידוד סופר-צפוף מאפשר
העברה של שני ביטים קלאסיים באמצעות
e-bit ו-qubit אחד של תקשורת קוונטית.
אז, בקיצור, קידוד סופר-צפוף מאפשר העברה
של מידע קלאסי והסיבה שזה נקרא
קידוד סופר-צפוף
היא שזה מאפשר העברה של שני
ביטים קלאסיים של תקשורת ל-qubit בודד,
אבל אנחנו צריכים לשרוף
e-bit כדי להשיג את זה.
הנה הסבר יותר מדויק
של ההגדרה.
שוב, יש לנו את Alice ו-Bob, כאשר Alice היא השולחת
ו-Bob הוא המקבל, והפעם ל-Alice יש שני ביטים קלאסיים
שהיא רוצה לשלוח ל-Bob.
Alice מסוגלת לשלוח ל-Bob qubit בודד ו-Alice ו-Bob חולקים
e-bit שהם יכולים להשתמש בו כדי לעזור להם להשיג את המשימה שלהם,
שהיא ש-Bob יקבל
את שני הביטים הקלאסיים.
עכשיו, יש מובן שבו המשימה הזו עשויה להיראות פחות מעניינת מהמשימה שטלפורטציה
משיגה,
במיוחד אם אנחנו רואים
ששליחת qubit-ים היא משמעותית יותר
קשה או מאתגרת משליחת ביטים קלאסיים,
שזו נקודת מבט די סבירה אבל זה בהחלט מעניין שאפשר לעשות את זה.
סיבה אחת למה זה מעניין
היא שזה למעשה בלתי אפשרי להשיג
את המשימה הזו של העברת שני ביטים קלאסיים של מידע
באמצעות qubit בודד בלי
להשתמש ב-e-bit.
אנחנו יודעים את זה בגלל משפט מפורסם שנקרא המשפט של Holevo.
המשפט של Holevo הוא
יותר כללי מזה, והניסוח המדויק
של המשפט של Holevo הוא קצת טכני והוא
דורש קצת הסבר,
אבל אחת ההשלכות שלו
היא שלא ניתן להעביר שום מספר של ביטים
קלאסיים של תקשורת באמצעות פחות qubit-ים של
תקשורת קוונטית בלבד.
אם אתם רוצים להעביר באופן אמין שני ביטים קלאסיים של
מידע באמצעות qubit-ים ואין לכם e-bit
להשתמש בו,
אתם תצטרכו לשלוח שני qubit-ים, אז הם יכולים גם לאחסן את הביטים שאתם רוצים להעביר.
סיבה נוספת למה קידוד
סופר-צפוף מעניין היא בגלל הקשר ההשלמתי
הקרוב שיש לו עם טלפורטציה, ו
נחזור לזה
קצת יותר מאוחר. הנה תיאור circuit קוונטי של פרוטוקול הקידוד הסופר-צפוף.
בשביל זה, לא
אפרט את כל הצעדים, אלא במקום זאת פשוט ניצמד לתיאור דיאגרמת ה-circuit.
כפי שאתם יכולים לראות, שוב
יש לנו את Alice ו-Bob, כאשר Alice למעלה
ו-Bob למטה.
הנה ה-e-bit שמשותף
בהתחלה בין Alice ו-Bob, שאיכשהו
הוקם לפני שהפרוטוקול הורץ.
ל-Alice יש שני ביטים קלאסיים, A ו-B, שאתם יכולים לראות כאן למעלה
ודרך הפרוטוקול שה-circuit מתאר,
שני הביטים הקלאסיים האלה
יגיעו לידיים של Bob.
יש רק qubit אחד
שחוצה את הקו בין Alice ל-Bob, וכמובן אין
ביטים קלאסיים שנשלחים,
העברה של
שני הביטים הקלאסיים היא מטרת הפרוטוקול.
תשימו לב גם שיש לו
בדיוק את אותם רכיבים שמשמשים בטלפורטציה, יש לנו controlled NOT
gate, Hadamard gate,
ו-Z ו-X-gate
שנשלטים על ידי ביטים קלאסיים.
אבל הם מסודרים אחרת, אז בואו נעבור לניתוח
כדי לראות איך זה עובד.
כדי לנתח איך קידוד סופר-צפוף עובד, בואו נתחיל בלכתוב
את בסיס Bell, שנמצא מאוד בלב
הניתוח.
מה שאנחנו הולכים לעשות הוא
קודם להסתכל על ההשפעה שלפעולות של Alice
יש על מצב Phi plus, ומה שנראה הוא
ש-Alice הופכת את
מצב Phi plus הזה לאחד
מארבעת מצבי Bell בהתאם לביטים
שהיא רוצה לשלוח.
אז, בואו נכתוב טבלה כדי שנוכל לעקוב
אחרי מה שקורה.
ראשית, אם A ו-B שניהם אפס, אז לא ה-Z-gate ולא
ה-X-gate מופעלים, אז הפעולות של Alice לא עושות שום דבר,
מה שאומר ש-Phi
plus ממופה ל-Phi plus.
אנחנו יכולים גם לבטא את זה כמשוואה כפי שאתם רואים ממש כאן,
שום דבר לא קורה ל-qubit של Alice ושום דבר לא קורה ל-qubit של Bob
ולעשות כלום מיוצג
על ידי מטריצת הזהות.
עכשיו, מה קורה אם A שווה לאפס ו-B שווה לאחד?
ובכן, בגלל ש-B שווה לאחד, אנחנו מפעילים את ה-Z-gate ו
לא מפעילים את ה-X-gate כי A שווה לאפס
ואנחנו רואים שההשפעה הכוללת היא ש-Alice מבצעת Z-gate.
Alice נמצאת מימין
כי היא למעלה, אם כי זה לא
באמת היה משנה במקרה הספציפי
הזה, ההשפעה היא ש
מצב Phi plus
ממופה ל-Phi minus, מה שאפשר לראות
מהביטויים האלה אם אתם זוכרים איך Z-gate עובד.
אז, אנחנו יכולים להוסיף את זה לטבלה שלנו, יש עוד שני מקרים לעבור, אם A שווה לאחד
ו-B שווה לאפס,
אז Alice מבצעת
X-gate שהופך Phi ל-Chi plus, ואם A שווה לאחד
ו-B שווה לאחד,
אז Alice מבצעת Z, ואז
X ואנחנו מקבלים Chi minus.
אז, הטבלה שלנו אומרת לנו מה קורה בארבעת המקרים האפשריים וזה ש-Alice למעשה בוחרת איזה
מארבעת מצבי Bell היא
רוצה לחלוק עם Bob, ויש לה חופש לבחור על ידי פעולה על ה-qubit שלה בלבד
וזה היבט די מעניין
של שזירה.
Alice אז שולחת את ה-qubit שלה
ל-Bob, בנקודה הזו, Bob מחזיק אחד מארבעת מצבי Bell והוא רק צריך
להבין איזה אחד זה
כדי לשחזר את הביטים.
ואנחנו יכולים לבדוק
שאכן controlled NOT gate ואחריו Hadamard gate
כפי שיש לנו בדיאגרמה עושה את הדבר הנכון.
לא אעבור על זה בפירוט, אבל אם תבחרו לעשות את זה, תגלו שההשפעה היא
כפי שאתם רואים כאן בטבלה.
דרך אחת לבדוק את
זה היא פשוט לחשב. לחלופין, אנחנו יכולים להכיר שאנחנו בעצם כבר
עברנו על זה בכיוון ההפוך
בשיעור הקודם. בשיעור הקודם
היה לנו את ה-Hadamard gate קודם ואת ה-controlled NOT gate אחריו
וראינו שה-circuit הזה
מיפה מצבי בסיס סטנדרטי למצבי Bell עם סימן
מינוס מעצבן באחד המקרים.
כשאנחנו הופכים את סדר ה-gate-ים ואנחנו לוקחים בחשבון
ששני ה-gate-ים האלה הם ההופכיים של עצמם,
מה שנקבל הוא ההופכי,
ואז מה שיש לנו במקרה
הזה הוא שהפעולה הולכת בכיוון ההפוך
וסימן המינוס יכול לבחור לאיזה
צד הוא רוצה להיות,
אבל מלבד זאת, הוא במקום שלו, ובנקודה הזו זה
מיידי שהמדידה חושפת את הערכים הנכונים,
סימן המינוס כאן לא מפריע לנו כי אחד מופיע עם
הסתברות אחד במקרה הזה, וזה כל מה שיש לניתוח.
בקצרה, Alice בוחרת מצב Bell ו-Bob מגלה איזה אחד זה.
רק כמה הערות קצרות
על קידוד סופר-צפוף לפני שנמשיך; ראשית, אנחנו צריכים להכיר
שקידוד סופר-צפוף
כנראה לא צפוי
להיות שימושי או מעשי בשום מובן כאמצעי
להעברת מידע קלאסי.
תקשורת קלאסית
היא מאוד זולה ושליחה פיזית של qubit-ים מאתגרת בלשון המעטה,
וכל עוד המצב כזה, לא היינו מצפים לשום
יתרון מעשי כלל מקידוד סופר-צפוף.
אבל רק בגלל שזה לא
צפוי להיות מעשי לא אומר שקידוד
סופר-צפוף לא מעניין.
זה מאוד מעניין למעשה, ראשית, הרעיון הבסיסי הוא
באמת די יסודי,
וכשאני מתייחס לרעיון הבסיסי, אני מתכוון לרעיון שאם Alice
חולקת מצב Bell עם Bob,
אז היא יכולה לבחור לשנות את המצב הזה לכל מצב Bell אחר ש
היא בוחרת הכל בעצמה, היא לא צריכה את העזרה של Bob
בשביל לעשות את זה.
זו דוגמה ספציפית
שנוגעת למצבי Bell, אבל יש רעיון בסיסי יותר כללי שנוגע לחופש שלשחקן אחד
יש להפוך מצב שזור שמשותף עם שחקן אחר, ולהבין בדיוק
מה החופש הזה הוא
זה צעד חשוב בהבנת מידע קוונטי ונראה בדיוק איך לתאר את החופש הזה במונחים פשוטים
ואלגנטיים ביחידה
השלישית של הסדרה.
קידוד סופר-צפוף גם
מספק דוגמה קונקרטית למה שאפשר לעשות עם שזירה, שהוא לאפשר העברה של שני ביטים קלאסיים
על ידי שליחת qubit בודד. כפי שכבר הזכרתי,
זה לא אפשרי באופן מוכח לפי המשפט של Holevo בלי שזירה.
אנחנו יכולים גם לשקול טלפורטציה וקידוד סופר-צפוף ביחד, ואנחנו רואים שהם
מבססים שקילות
בין qubit אחד של תקשורת קוונטית לשני ביטים של תקשורת קלאסית.
כל עוד אתם מוכנים
להוציא e-bit אחד, אתם יכולים למעשה
להמיר אחד לשני.
טלפורטציה מאפשרת
תקשורת של qubit אחד באמצעות שני ביטים קלאסיים של תקשורת וקידוד סופר-צפוף הולך בכיוון ההפוך
ומאפשר שני ביטים
קלאסיים של תקשורת באמצעות qubit אחד של תקשורת קוונטית.
בלי להוציא את ה-e-bit, עם זאת, אי אפשר להפוך
אף אחד מהם לשני, שזירה היא מה
שמאפשר את זה.
הדוגמה השלישית והאחרונה
שנכסה בשיעור הזה היא לא פרוטוקול אלא
משחק שנקרא משחק CHSH.
כשאנחנו מדברים על משחק בהקשר הזה, אנחנו לא מדברים על משהו שנועד להיות
משוחק לכיף או לספורט,
אלא הפשטה מתמטית במובן של תורת המשחקים למשל.
הפשטות מתמטיות של משחקים נחקרות מאוד נפוץ ב
כלכלה ומדעי המחשב, למשל, ויש
ערך רב
בהפשטה, אז משחקים זה לא הכל כיף
במשחקים כפי שמתברר,
למרות שזה כן כיף לחשוב עליהם.
במקרה הספציפי הזה, מה שיש לנו הוא בעצם
ניסוי מחשבתי שאפשר לתאר בצורה
די אינטואיטיבית כמשחק.
האותיות CHSH מתייחסות למחברים, John Clauser, Michael
Horne, Abner Shimony, ו-Richard Holt של מאמר מ-1969
שבו הדוגמה
תוארה לראשונה. הם לא תיארו
אותה כמשחק, למעשה, וזה די נפוץ
להתייחס לדוגמה הזו
לא כמשחק CHSH, אלא
כאי-השוויון של CHSH.
עבור מדען מחשב כמוני, עם זאת, זה פשוט מאוד טבעי
לתאר את זה כמשחק.
כבר הצעתי
שהפשטות מתמטיות של משחקים הן גם חשובות וגם שימושיות ויש הרבה קטגוריות שונות
של משחקים
שאפשר לשקול. משחק CHSH הוא
דוגמה למחלקה של משחקים שנקראת משחקים לא-מקומיים.
הנה ההגדרה באופן כללי
של משחק לא-מקומי.
יש לנו שני שחקנים, Alice ו-Bob, שמשתפים פעולה כצוות, אז הם או מנצחים ביחד
או מפסידים ביחד.
זה אומר שאין להם
תמריץ לפעול באנוכיות, אז זה בעצם הקיצוניות
ההפוכה ממשחקי סכום אפס,
שהם תחרותיים לחלוטין, כאן המשחק הוא שיתופי לחלוטין.
יש ישות שלישית שנקראת השופט.
השופט הוא לא שחקן במשחק, אלא השופט
מריץ את המשחק, ולמעשה, אתם יכולים לחשוב על המפרט
של מופע מסוים
של משחק לא-מקומי ועל המפרט של
שופט כשווי ערך.
יש אילוץ קריטי שמוטל על Alice ו-Bob, שהוא שברגע שהמשחק מתחיל, אסור להם
לתקשר אחד עם השני.
הם יכולים להסכים מראש על
כל אסטרטגיה שהם בוחרים, אבל שום תקשורת
לא מותרת ביניהם במהלך המשחק עצמו.
אם אתם רוצים, אתם יכולים
לדמיין שהמשחק מתקיים במתקן מאובטח מסוג כלשהו כאילו השופט ממלא
את התפקיד של בלש
ו-Alice ו-Bob הם חשודים שנמצאים בחדרים שונים
בתחנת משטרה, אבל דרך אחרת לחשוב
על ההגדרה
היא ש-Alice ו-Bob
מופרדים על ידי מרחק עצום ותקשורת אסורה כי מהירות האור
לא מאפשרת תקשורת
להתרחש מספיק מהר. אם Alice מנסה לשלוח
הודעה ל-Bob למשל, המשחק יסתיים עד
שBob יקבל אותה.
הדרך שבה משחק לא-מקומי
עובד היא שקודם, השופט שואל גם את
Alice וגם את Bob שאלה.
השאלה של Alice מסומנת X והשאלה של Bob מסומנת Y.
באופן כללי, אתם יכולים לחשוב על X ו-Y כמצבים קלאסיים
מכל מצבים קלאסיים שתרצו ובמקרה
הספציפי של משחק CHSH,
X ו-Y הם ביטים.
Alice ו-Bob חייבים אז לספק תשובות, התשובה של Alice מסומנת A,
והתשובה של Bob מסומנת B,
ושוב, התשובות האלה אפשר לראות כמצבים קלאסיים באופן כללי וכמו השאלות, הן
יהיו ביטים במשחק CHSH.
בנקודה הזו,
השופט מקבל החלטה, Alice ו-Bob או מנצחים או מפסידים בהתאם לכך אם
זוג התשובות A, B
נחשב נכון עבור
זוג השאלות X, Y שהשופט שאל, ואגיד עוד קצת
על זה עוד רגע.
ראשית, בואו נסתכל
מקרוב על השופט כדי להבין מה זה
שעלול להיות מאתגר ל-Alice ול-Bob במשחק לא-מקומי.
ומה שהופך משחק לא-מקומי
לפוטנציאלית מאתגר הוא שהשופט יכול להשתמש באקראיות כדי לבחור את השאלות X ו-Y.
זה אומר ש-Alice
ו-Bob נמצאים באי-ודאות, הם לא יודעים מראש איזו שאלה ישאלו אותם, ואולי חשוב יותר,
הם לא יודעים איזו שאלה
השני קיבל ואי-הודאות הזו
ביחד עם העובדה שהם לא יכולים לתקשר
היא מה שמציג את האתגר.
אז, זה דומה למצב שבו בלש
חוקר שני חשודים בחדרים שונים, אם
החשודים לא יודעים
אילו שאלות נשאל השני, הרבה יותר קשה אם הם אשמים לשמור על הסיפור שלהם עקבי.
עכשיו, הזכרתי לפני
זמן קצר שהשופט קובע
ש-Alice ו-Bob ענו או
נכון או לא נכון
בהתאם לשאלות
שנשאלו.
מניחים שקביעה
זו נעשית לפי כלל קבוע כלשהו ואתם יכולים לשקול כל כלל שתרצו,
אבל מה שזה לא יהיה,
מניחים ש-Alice
ו-Bob יודעים את הכלל, אז לפחות יש להם סיכוי
לענות נכון.
נסתכל על הכלל
של משחק CHSH עוד רגע, אבל אנחנו יכולים
לשקול כלל שונה ואז היה לנו דוגמה שונה
של משחק לא-מקומי.
חלק מהמשחקים הלא-מקומיים מעניינים ולמעשה חלקם מרתקים ומסתוריים עד היום ו
חלקם לא כל כך מעניינים,
זה פשוט הטבע של
מודל המשחק הלא-מקומי.
בכל מקרה, אלה שני הדברים השונים שנדרשים כדי לתאר שופט; איך בדיוק נבחרות השאלות
ואילו זוגות תשובות נכונים עבור כל זוג שאלות אפשרי.
אם יש לנו תיאור
של שני הדברים האלה, אז יש לנו תיאור של השופט וזה למעשה מתאר
מופע של משחק לא-מקומי.
עכשיו בואו נסתכל על
משחק CHSH באופן ספציפי.
הדרך שבה המשחק
מוגדר או, באופן שווה, איך השופט מוגדר היא כדלקמן;
ראשית, כפי שכבר הזכרתי, השאלות והתשובות הן כולן ביטים, אז השופט שולח ביט X
ל-Alice וביט Y ל-Bob,
וכל אחד מהם עונה בביט. Alice עונה עם A
ו-Bob עונה עם B.
הדרך שבה השופט בוחר
אילו שאלות לשאול היא פשוטה, הוא בוחר
אותן באופן אחיד ואקראי,
אז, זוג השאלות X, Y סביר באותה מידה להיות כל אחת
מארבע האפשרויות, אפס, אפס, אפס, אחד,
אחד, אפס, ואחד, אחד.
לבסוף, הכלל שקובע
אילו תשובות מנצחות ואילו מפסידות הוא
שזוג תשובות A, B נכון עבור זוג השאלות X, Y
אם ורק אם ה-XOR של A ו-B שווה ל-AND הלוגי של X ו-Y.
זה אולי קצת יותר קל לעכל אם נבטא את התנאים האלה
בצורת טבלה כפי שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
בעמודה הראשונה, יש לנו את ארבעת זוגות השאלות האפשריים, ובעמודה השנייה יש לנו
את התנאים על A ו-B
שנדרשים כדי
ש-Alice ו-Bob ינצחו.
בשלושת המקרים הראשונים,
ה-AND של A ו-Y הוא אפס, אז ה-XOR חייב להיות שווה לאפס
כדי שהם ינצחו,
וזה אותו דבר כמו לומר ש-A ו-B חייבים להיות שווים כי A ו-B הם ביטים,
ובמקרה הרביעי,
ה-AND של X ו-Y שווה
לאחד ואז ה-XOR של A ו-B חייב להיות שווה לאחד כדי ש-Alice ו-Bob ינצחו
וזה אותו דבר
כמו לומר ש-A ו-B חייבים להיות שונים.
אז, זה משחק CHSH, ועכשיו אנחנו יכולים לחשוב על
אסטרטגיות שונות אפשריות ל-Alice ול-Bob ועד כמה
טוב הם יכולים להצליח במשחק הזה.
בואו נתחיל בלחשוב על
אסטרטגיות דטרמיניסטיות שבהן התשובה A של Alice היא
פונקציה של השאלה X שהיא מקבלת, ו
באותו אופן, התשובה B של Bob
היא פונקציה של
השאלה Y שהוא מקבל.
וכפי שמתברר, שום
אסטרטגיה דטרמיניסטית לא יכולה לנצח בכל פעם.
דרך אחת להסיק את זה היא
פשוט לעבור אחד אחד על כל האסטרטגיות
הדטרמיניסטיות האפשריות ולבדוק שכל אחת מהן מפסידה
לפחות עבור אחד מארבעת
זוגות השאלות האפשריים.
ל-Alice ול-Bob, לכל אחד
יש ארבע פונקציות אפשריות לבחור מהן, ראינו את
ארבע הפונקציות האלה בשיעור הראשון, אז יש 16 אפשרויות
לבדוק בסך הכל.
דרך אחרת לראות את זה היא
לחשוב על המשוואות כאן על המסך, אנחנו חושבים
על אסטרטגיות דטרמיניסטיות
שבהן A ו-B הם פונקציות
של X ו-Y בהתאמה.
אז למשל, A של אפס
מייצג את התשובה של Alice כאשר השאלה X שלה שווה לאפס ו-A של אחד מייצג את התשובה של Alice
כאשר השאלה X שלה שווה לאחד.
אלה ארבע המשוואות
שחייבות להיות נכונות כדי שתנאי
הניצחון יתקיימו בכל אחד מארבעת המקרים.
למשל, אם X שווה
לאפס ו-Y שווה לאפס, אז ה-XOR של A
ו-B חייב להיות שווה לאפס,
ואילו במקרה ש-X שווה לאחד ו-Y שווה לאחד, ה-
XOR של A ו-B חייב להיות שווה לאחד.
דרך אחת שאנחנו יכולים לראות
שאין דרך לבחור את הפונקציות A ו-B כך ש
המשוואות האלה כולן נכונות, היא פשוט לקחת את ה-
XOR של כל המשוואות.
ה-XOR של כל ערך
בינארי עם עצמו שווה לאפס, ומזה נובע שה-XOR
של האגפים השמאליים
שווה לאפס, זה
בגלל שיש לנו שני מופעים של A אפס, שני מופעים של A אחד,
שני מופעים של B אפס
ושני מופעים של B אחד.
אז, XOR של כולם ביחד
נותן לנו תשובה סופית של אפס, אבל אם ניקח את ה-XOR של האגפים הימניים של המשוואות,
נקבל אחד ולא אפס. אז ארבע המשוואות
לא יכולות כולן להיות נכונות, לפחות אחת מהן חייבת להיות שגויה
וזה יוביל להפסד
של Alice ו-Bob לפחות באחד מארבעת המקרים.
ומזה נובע כי השופט בוחר את השאלות
באופן אחיד שההסתברות ל-Alice ול-Bob לנצח
באמצעות אסטרטגיה דטרמיניסטית
היא לכל היותר שלושה רבעים או 75%.
העובדה ש-Alice ו-Bob יכולים לנצח בהסתברות שלושה רבעים די קלה לראות
בעצם, אם Alice ו-Bob שניהם עונים אפס כל
הזמן, למשל,
הם יהיו נכונים שלוש
מתוך ארבע פעמים.
אז Alice ו-Bob לא יכולים לעשות
יותר טוב מלנצח 75% מהזמן באמצעות
אסטרטגיה דטרמיניסטית.
אבל מה לגבי אסטרטגיה הסתברותית?
ובכן, מתברר שהשימוש
באסטרטגיה הסתברותית לא יכול לעזור להם כלל, זה בגלל שכל
אסטרטגיה הסתברותית
אפשר לחלופין לראות
כבחירה אקראית של אסטרטגיה דטרמיניסטית בדיוק כמו שפעולות
הסתברותיות אפשר לראות
כבחירות אקראיות של
פעולות דטרמיניסטיות, כפי שראינו בשיעור הראשון.
הממוצע אף פעם לא
גדול מהמקסימום, אז מזה נובע ש
אסטרטגיה הסתברותית לא מציעה שום יתרון
במונחים של ניצחון
על פני אסטרטגיה דטרמיניסטית. זה כולל אפילו את האפשרות שהבחירות האקראיות של Alice ו-Bob מתואמות.
אז, בשורה התחתונה, לנצח בהסתברות שלושה רבעים זה הטוב ביותר ש-Alice
ו-Bob יכולים להשיג באמצעות כל אסטרטגיה קלאסית,
בין אם היא דטרמיניסטית
או הסתברותית.
השאלה הטבעית לשאול בנקודה הזו היא האם Alice ו-Bob יכולים לעשות יותר טוב באמצעות אסטרטגיה קוונטית,
ובפרט
אם הם חולקים מצב קוונטי שזור שהם יכלו להכין
לפני המשחק, האם זה יכול לעזור להם?
התשובה היא כן, זה יכול, וזו הנקודה של הדוגמה ולכן היא כל כך מעניינת.
אז בואו נראה בדיוק איך
Alice ו-Bob יכולים לעשות יותר טוב במשחק הזה באמצעות שזירה.
הדבר הראשון שאנחנו צריכים לעשות הוא להגדיר וקטור מצב קוונטי Chi
תטא עבור כל זווית תטא, כפי שאתם רואים כאן על המסך.
אז, Chi תטא שווה ל
קוסינוס תטא כפול קט אפס ועוד סינוס תטא כפול קט
אחד, וכאן אגב,
אנחנו חושבים על
זוויות במונחי רדיאנים.
אז למשל, הנה הוקטור שנקבל כאשר תטא שווה ל-פאי חלקי
ארבע, שזה 45 מעלות.
קוסינוס של פאי חלקי ארבע
וסינוס של פאי חלקי ארבע שניהם שווים לאחד חלקי
שורש ריבועי של שתיים, אז זה רק שם אחר
למצב הפלוס.
הנה דוגמה נוספת כאשר תטא שווה לשלוש כפול פאי חלקי שמונה, ולמקרה שאתם לא
יודעים במקרה את הסינוס
והקוסינוס של שלוש כפול פאי חלקי שמונה מהראש,
הנה טבלה של הסינוסים והקוסינוסים שאנחנו באמת
הולכים להזדקק להם
לאורך הדוגמה הזו
וכוללת את אלה שאנחנו צריכים עבור הוקטור הספציפי הזה.
עכשיו, אם אנחנו רוצים לקחת את המכפלה הפנימית בין כל שניים מהוקטורים האלה
עבור זוויות, אלפא ובטא נגיד, זה
פשוט לעשות את זה.
יש לנו רק ערכים
ממשיים בוקטורים האלה אז אין צמודים
מרוכבים לדאוג לגביהם ונקבל את המכפלה של הקוסינוסים
ועוד המכפלה של הסינוסים, ואנחנו יכולים להשתמש באחת
מנוסחאות חיבור הזוויות
כדי לפשט את זה, זה
הקוסינוס של ההפרש בין הזוויות ו
כיוון שפונקציית הקוסינוס
סימטרית סביב אפס,
לא באמת משנה באיזה סדר ניקח אותן.
אם אין לכם את סוגי
הזהויות הטריגונומטריות האלה בזיכרון,
אגב, אתם לא לבד, אבל אתם לא חייבים לזכור אותן,
אתם יכולים פשוט לחפש אותן. זו כן הגיונית
אם כי כשחושבים על הפרשנות הגאומטרית
של המכפלה הפנימית
בין וקטורי יחידה ממשיים כקוסינוס הזווית ביניהם.
אם נחשב את המכפלה
הפנימית של המכפלה הטנזורית של כל שניים מהוקטורים האלה
עם מצב Phi plus, נקבל ביטוי דומה
חוץ מזה שיש שורש
ריבועי של שתיים במכנה.
זו הפעם הראשונה
שמצב Phi plus מופיע בהקשר
של הדוגמה הזו אגב, ונראה בדיוק למה אנחנו מתעניינים
במכפלה הפנימית הספציפית הזו בקרוב, אבל לרגע בואו
רק נשים לב שנקבל את אותו ביטוי שהיה לנו
עבור המכפלה הפנימית חלקי
שורש ריבועי של שתיים ואז אנחנו יכולים לפשט כמו קודם.
בשלב הבא, נגדיר
מטריצה אוניטרית, U תטא, עבור כל זווית תטא
כפי שאתם רואים ממש כאן,
לא קשה לבדוק
שזו אכן מטריצה אוניטרית.
הדבר המרכזי שאנחנו צריכים
להכיר הוא שהוקטור si תטא מאונך ל
וקטור si תטא ועוד פאי חלקי שתיים, וזה הגיוני
כי אם נסובב ב-פאי חלקי שתיים, שזה 90 מעלות,
נקבל וקטור מאונך.
אם נכפול את U
תטא ב-U תטא דאגר, נקבל את מטריצת הזהות.
באינטואיציה,
מה שהמטריצה הזו עושה כפעולה היא
למפות si תטא לקט אפס ו-si תטא ועוד פאי חלקי שתיים לקט אחד.
בנקודה הזו, יש לנו
את כל מה שאנחנו צריכים כדי לתאר את האסטרטגיה של Alice ו-Bob.
ראשית, בדיוק כמו שהיה לנו עבור טלפורטציה וקידוד סופר-צפוף, Alice ו-Bob יתחילו בחלוקת e-bit.
Alice מחזיקה qubit A,
Bob מחזיק qubit B, וביחד שני ה-qubit-ים
נמצאים במצב Phi plus.
הפעולות של Alice הן כדלקמן; היא מסתכלת על הביט X שהיא
מקבלת מהשופט,
ואם X שווה לאפס,
היא מבצעת U אפס על A, שזה במקרה
אותו דבר כמו לא לעשות כלום כי U אפס היא מטריצת הזהות,
אם X שווה לאחד מצד שני, היא מפעילה U פאי חלקי ארבע על A.
אחרי שהיא מפעילה אחת
משתי הפעולות, היא מודדת את A באמצעות
מדידת בסיס סטנדרטי ושולחת כל תוצאה
שהיא מקבלת לשופט.
Bob עושה משהו מאוד דומה, ה-qubit שלו נקרא B כמובן, והוא מקבל Y מה
שופט לעומת X
אבל ההבדל המרכזי הוא
שהוא משתמש בזוויות שונות לפעולות האוניטריות שלו.
אם Y שווה לאפס, הוא
מפעיל U פאי חלקי שמונה, ואם Y שווה לאחד, הוא מפעיל U מינוס פאי חלקי שמונה.
ונראה למה הבחירות האלה של זוויות הן בחירות טובות בקרוב,
זה בכלל לא מובן מאליו.
והנה דיאגרמת circuit
שמבטאת את האסטרטגיה הזו.
Bob נמצא למעלה ו-Alice
למטה הפעם, הנה ה-e-bit שנכנס
ואלה ה-gate-ים האוניטריים
ש-Alice ו-Bob עשויים או לא עשויים להפעיל
בהתאם למה ש-X ו-Y הם.
עבור זה וזה, יש לנו gate-ים שנשלטים או על ידי הביט X או על ידי הביט Y
ועבור אלה שכאן, יש לנו מה שנראה
כמו control gate-ים חוץ מזה שהעיגול לא מלא.
ומה שזה אומר הוא
שאם ביט הבקרה מוגדר לאפס, אז ה-gate מבוצע ואם הבקרה מוגדרת ל
אחד, אז שום דבר לא קורה.
אז, זה בדיוק כמו
control gate רגיל חוץ מזה שהתפקידים של אפס ואחד עבור הבקרה מוחלפים.
אז, למעשה, Bob
מבצע את ה-gate הזה כאן אם Y שווה לאפס, הוא
מבצע את ה-gate הזה כאן
אם Y שווה לאחד, ובאותו אופן, Alice מבצעת את ה-gate הזה
כאן אם X שווה לאפס, ואת ה-gate הזה כאן,
אם X שווה לאחד.
אז, זו האסטרטגיה של Alice ו-Bob ועכשיו אנחנו רק צריכים
להבין כמה טוב היא עובדת.
לניתוח של האסטרטגיה הקוונטית שתיארתי עכשיו, אנחנו
באמת צריכים רק שני דברים בנקודה הזו, ראשית, המטריצה
האוניטרית U תטא
היא כפי שאתם רואים ממש כאן, ו
שנית היה לנו את הנוסחה הזו.
אנחנו בעצם אפילו לא צריכים את ההגדרה של הוקטור si תטא יותר, שתי המשוואות האלה הן כל מה שאנחנו צריכים.
יש ארבעה מקרים
לשקול, מתחילים עם מקרה ראשון, שהוא ש-X שווה
אפס ו-Y שווה אפס.
ואם נסתכל חזרה על האסטרטגיה, נגלה שבמקרה
הזה Alice מבצעת U אפס על ה-qubit שלה ו-Bob מבצע
U פאי חלקי שמונה על ה-qubit שלו.
זכרו, Alice נמצאת
למטה ו-Bob למעלה, אז המצב שהם
מקבלים נראה ככה.
ועל ידי פריסת זה
לפי ההגדרה של U תטא, נקבל את
הביטוי הזה שאתם רואים ממש כאן.
אנחנו לא צריכים לפרוש
את זה יותר כי יש לנו את הנוסחה
השנייה שעוזרת לנו.
ואם נפעיל את הנוסחה הזו
עבור כל אחד מארבעת האיברים, מה שנקבל זה את זה.
בנקודה הזו Alice ו-Bob שניהם מודדים והנה טבלה שמסבירה
את ההתפלגות של התוצאות.
אנחנו לוקחים את הערך
המוחלט בריבוע של המקדמים כדי לקבל את ההסתברויות, שבמקרה הן
ריבועים של המקדמים
כי המקדמים הם
כולם מספרים ממשיים במקרה הזה.
אם נשתמש בערכי
הסינוס והקוסינוס מקודם בשיעור
ביחד עם כמה סימטריות, אנחנו יכולים לבטא את ההסתברויות האלה
כפי שיש לנו ממש כאן
בעמודה האחרונה.
עכשיו, מה שבאמת אכפת
לנו ממנו הוא ההסתברות שהם מנצחים, וזכרו שבמקרה ש-X ו-Y שניהם אפס,
הם מנצחים אם A ו-B שווים והם מפסידים אם A ו-B לא שווים.
אם נחשב את ההסתברויות האלה, נגלה שההסתברות
ש-A ו-B שווים היא הסכום של המספר הזה והמספר הזה,
שזה שווה לשתיים ועוד
שורש שתיים הכל חלקי ארבע, שזה בערך 85%.
ההסתברות ש-A ו-B לא שווים היא שתיים פחות שורש שתיים הכל חלקי ארבע, שזה באופן טבעי אחד פחות הכמות
שחישבנו עכשיו, אז
הם מנצחים בהסתברות של בערך 85% במקרה הזה.
יש עוד שלושה מקרים לשקול, אבל כולם מאוד דומים לזה,
במקרה ש-X שווה
אפס ו-Y שווה אחד, Bob מפעיל U מינוס פאי חלקי שמונה במקום U פאי חלקי שמונה,
הערכים בנוסחאות
משתנים קצת, אבל אנחנו מסיימים עם בדיוק
אותן הסתברויות שהיו לנו במקרה הקודם.
כאשר X שווה אפס ו-Y שווה אחד, Alice ו-Bob עדיין מנצחים
כאשר A ו-B שווים ואז יש לנו בדיוק את
אותה הסתברות ניצחון
כמו קודם.
במקרה השלישי, כאשר X שווה לאחד ו-Y שווה לאפס,
יש לנו מצב דומה, הזוויות שונות,
אבל יש להן בדיוק
את אותו יחס
ביניהן, ולמעשה, אנחנו מקבלים בדיוק
את אותו וקטור שקיבלנו במקרה הקודם.
אז ההסתברויות זהות וכך גם הסתברות הניצחון.
המקרה האחרון קצת
שונה כפי שאנחנו עשויים לצפות כי תנאי הניצחון
שונה במקרה הזה.
כאשר X ו-Y שניהם שווים לאחד, Alice ו-Bob מנצחים כאשר
A ו-B שונים.
השיטה הבסיסית זהה, למרות שהזוויות שונות, הפעם, אנחנו מקבלים את הוקטור הזה כאן
ואתם יכולים לבדוק את זה על ידי מעבר על החיסורים הנדרשים.
ההסתברויות כן משתנות סוף סוף, ואם נבדוק את הערכים שאנחנו צריכים, נראה שההסתברויות
למעשה
החליפו מיקומים מקודם, אז הפעם זו ההסתברות
ש-A לא שווה ל-B, שהיא הגדולה מבין השתיים,
אבל זה טוב כי במקרה הזה, Alice ו-Bob מנצחים כאשר
A ו-B לא שווים.
אז שוב, הם מנצחים בהסתברות
של בערך 85%.
בהתחשב בכך שהם מנצחים בכל
מקרה באותה הסתברות, שהיא שתיים ועוד שורש שתיים
הכל חלקי ארבע או בערך 85%,
זו ההסתברות
שהם מנצחים בסך הכל.
זה יותר טוב ממה שכל אסטרטגיה קלאסית יכולה להשיג במשחק הזה, וזה
מה שהופך את זה למעניין.
זו במקרה
הסתברות הניצחון האופטימלית עבור כל אסטרטגיה קוונטית, אי
אפשר לעשות יותר טוב מזה באמצעות שום מצב שזור.
העובדה הזו ידועה כאי-השוויון של Tsirelson, היא נקראת על שם Boris
Tsirelson שהוכיח אותה ראשון, ולפי מיטב ידיעתי היה
אחד מהאנשים הראשונים
שתיארו את הדוגמה הזו כמשחק. למקרה שהניתוח
שעברנו עכשיו נראה קצת מסתורי,
אפשר לחשוב
על זה גאומטרית, מה שעשוי לעזור
לתת לכם תחושה טובה יותר עבור בחירת הזוויות.
ספציפית, אם נשתמש
בנוסחה שאתם רואים ממש כאן, שאנחנו יכולים בקלות להסיק
מהביטויים
שכבר מצאנו עבור
המכפלות הפנימיות המעורבות, אז אנחנו יכולים לחלופין
לבטא את ההסתברויות של תוצאות המדידה
השונות האפשריות
בארבעת המקרים כדלקמן; ראשית, אם X, Y שווה אפס, אפס, אז אלה ההסתברויות
של תוצאות המדידה השונות, ואתם צריכים או לחשוב אחורה או להסתכל אחורה על הניתוח
שעברנו עכשיו כדי להסיק את זה באמצעות הנוסחה שלנו.
כאן, אנחנו יכולים לראות את
וקטורי המצב השונים מצוירים כפי שהיו קודם, וקוד הצבעים כאן
הוא שכחול מתאים
לתוצאה אפס ואדום
מתאים לתוצאה אחד.
אתם יכולים לראות שהזווית
בין הוקטורים הכחולים והזווית בין הוקטורים
האדומים היא יחסית קטנה,
זה פאי חלקי שמונה בשני המקרים, אז הקוסינוס יחסית גדול, וזה אומר שה
הסתברות ששתי התוצאות
שוות היא יחסית גדולה.
במקרה ש-X, Y שווה אפס, אחד, זה מצב דומה, ה
זוויות בין הוקטורים בעלי אותו צבע קטנות,
אז ההסתברות של
תוצאות שוות היא שוב, יחסית גדולה.
המקרה השלישי דומה, ובמקרה הרביעי
כאשר X, Y שווה אחד, אחד, משהו מעניין קורה, הפעם, רק בגלל הדרך,
שהוקטורים האלה נבחרו, אנחנו רואים שהזוויות בין
וקטורים בעלי אותו צבע
הן יחסית גדולות, וספציפית הזוויות הן שלוש כפול
פאי חלקי שמונה בשני המקרים.
זה אומר שההסתברות
שתוצאות המדידה שוות היא יחסית קטנה, אבל זה המקרה היחיד
שבו Alice ו-Bob מנצחים
כאשר התשובות שלהם לא מסכימות,
אז זה מה שאנחנו רוצים.
שוב, הנה הוקטורים: כאשר X, Y שווה אפס, אפס,
כאשר X, Y שווה אפס, אחד,
כאשר X, Y שווה אחד, אפס,
וכאשר X, Y שווה אחד, אחד.
ואולי התמונה הגאומטרית
הזו מועילה לבניית אינטואיציה
לאיך האסטרטגיה הזו עובדת
ולמה הזוויות השונות האלה נבחרו בדרך שבה הן נבחרו.
לסיום השיעור, אעשה כמה הערות קצרות
על משחק CHSH.
ראשית, כפי שכבר הזכרתי, הדוגמה הזו לא תמיד
מתוארת כמשחק.
בקהילת הפיזיקה, למשל, יותר נפוץ שהדוגמה
מתוארת פשוט כניסוי ולא כמשחק
ו-Alice ו-Bob נתפסים
כגלאים ולא כשחקנים.
הרעיון הבסיסי של ניסוי כזה שבו שזירה מובילה
לתוצאות סטטיסטיות שלא עקביות עם
שום תיאור קלאסי
או באופן כללי יותר כל
תיאוריה המבוססת על מה שנקרא משתנים חבויים מקומיים,
שייך ל-John Bell, שעל שמו נקראו מצבי Bell,
ולכן אנשים לעיתים קרובות מתייחסים
לניסויים מסוג זה כמבחני Bell.
לפעמים אנשים גם
מתייחסים למשפט של Bell, שאפשר לנסח בדרכים שונות, אבל הוא בעצם אומר
שמכניקת הקוונטים
לא תואמת לתיאוריות של מה שנקרא משתנים חבויים מקומיים.
משחק CHSH או אי-השוויון הוא בעצם דוגמה מאוד יפה ונקייה
של מבחן Bell,
ואתם יכולים לחשוב
על הדוגמה הזו כהוכחה או הדגמה של משפט Bell.
ההערה השנייה היא שמשחק CHSH מציע לנו דרך אחת לבדוק ניסויית שתורת המידע הקוונטי
היא תיאוריה מדויקת. אנחנו יכולים בפועל להקים ניסויים שמיישמים את משחק CHSH,
כולל את סוג
האסטרטגיה המבוססת על שזירה שתיארתי עכשיו, ו
לראות אם זה עובד, וזה עובד.
זה מספק לנו רמת
ביטחון גבוהה ששזירה היא אמיתית, ובשונה מהדרכים אולי
המעורפלות או הפואטיות
שאנחנו מנסים להמציא
כדי להסביר שזירה, משחק CHSH או הניסוי
נותן לנו דרך קונקרטית
וניתנת לבדיקה לצפות בשזירה.
אם זה נשמע חשוב,
זה בגלל שזה חשוב, ופרס נובל
בפיזיקה לשנת 2022 מכיר בדיוק בזה.
הפרס הוענק ל-
Alain Aspect, John Clauser, שהוא ה-C ב-CHSH, ו-Anton Zeilinger
עבור ניסויים עם פוטונים שזורים שהוכיחו את ההפרה
של אי-שוויונות Bell, או במילים אחרות,
שהראו שאסטרטגיות קוונטיות
מהסוג שתיארתי באמת עובדות ומצליחות יותר מאסטרטגיות קלאסיות.
ואם אתם מעוניינים
ללמוד עוד על זה, אני מעודד אתכם לבדוק את
הסרטון על משפט Bell מאת עמיתתי Olivia Lanes,
ממש כאן בערוץ היוטיוב של Qiskit.
ולבסוף, הנושא של
משחקים לא-מקומיים באופן כללי יותר הוא באמת מרתק, וזה
תחום מחקר פעיל
שמפגיש ביחד
פיזיקה, מדעי המחשב, ומתמטיקה טהורה ויש עדיין הרבה
שאלות מעניינות
על משחקים לא-מקומיים שנשארות
ללא מענה עד היום.
וזה הסוף של שיעור ארבע, וגם הסוף של
יחידה אחת של הסדרה על היסודות של מידע קוונטי.
השיעור הראשון הסביר
איך מידע קוונטי עובד למערכות בודדות בבידוד, והשיעור השני הסביר
איך מידע קוונטי
עובד למערכות מרובות,
מה שעולה די טבעי מאיך שזה עובד למערכות בודדות.
השיעור השלישי הציג
את מודל ה-circuit הקוונטי של חישוב, ובשיעור הרביעי, הסתכלנו על שלוש דוגמאות חשובות
שממחישות דברים שאנחנו
יכולים לעשות עם שזירה.
לאורך הדרך, ראינו כמה מושגים מתמטיים מאוד חשובים,
כולל מכפלות טנזוריות ומכפלות פנימיות, וראינו
כמה מגבלות בסיסיות
של מידע קוונטי.
אני מקווה שתצטרפו אליי ל
יחידה הבאה של הסדרה, שתהיה על אלגוריתמים קוונטיים, שם נתמקד בשאלה
אילו יתרונות חישוביים
מידע קוונטי מציע.
להתראות עד אז.